what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have a lot of Fantastic Four News
to go over today yes we have a lot of
casting news to go over that you might
have heard recently it's very
controversial as it would have an actor
who already has played a character in
the MCU playing another character in The
MCO however from what we are hearing the
character could be from a completely
different Universe in fact a report that
we got yesterday states that the entire
Fantastic Four movie could be set in an
entirely different Universe than the
main Earth 616 universe and I actually
think this is a very creative idea that
could work in the MCU leading up to
Secret Wars however some people might
not like the idea of what Marvel Studios
could be planning for the Fantastic Four
but go ahead and after this video is
done let us know what you think what is
your opinion so we'll talk about this
major plot point of the Fantastic Four
and the casting news of course in this
video and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news also if you subscribe
and leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 and Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items winner
picks one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month so yesterday some
pretty big news dropped by The Insider
my time to shine hello she stated
sources confirmed that right before the
strikes Matt Smith passed on the role of
Reed Richards in Fantastic Four now we
know that Marvel Studios is really
searching for their Mr Fantastic and as
far as we're concerned according to
multiple insiders right now Vanessa
Kirby is playing Sue storm according to
multiple insiders Marvel Studios offered
her the role of Sue storm and she
accepted which I hope is true because I
really like Vanessa Kirby and I think
this is a great casting choice now Matt
Smith was the latest actor to be rumored
to be up for the role of Reed Richards
aka Mr Fantastic in the MCU that Marvel
Studios wanted but now it looks like
according to my time to shine hello yes
passed on the roll more info on this in
a bit but to finish what my time to
shine hello stated she continued in her
tweet and the next one to get an offer
is no Less Than Jake Gyllenhaal the
weird part is that he already played a
role in the MCU Mysterio and Spider-Man
far from home now many of you might have
heard about this yesterday but due to a
recent explanation this kind of does
make sense right off the bat though it
is rather interesting Jake Gyllenhaal
did play Mysterio and as far as we're
concerned he was lying when he said that
he was from Another Universe and he was
indeed from our main universe so of
course the big question is well how
could Marvel Studios get Jake Gyllenhaal
to play Reed Richards of the Fantastic
Four if he has already played a
character Mysterio in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe already well it
appears the answer to that could be he's
not actually going to be from the same
universe which if they are going to cast
Jake Gyllenhaal as Reed Richards I say
this is the way to go because I really
would not like one actor play kind of
the same role especially when those
roles are super big this has been done a
few times but not on such a large scale
for example Jimmy Chan she played a
small role in Captain Marvel did you all
know that because a lot of people didn't
really know that when the eternals came
out because she went on to then play
Cersei and the internals and as far as
we're concerned she is going to return
in the eternals too but the role that
she played in Captain Marvel Min irva
wasn't exactly the biggest role of the
movie and her characters look very very
different for one in Captain Marvel
she's a Cree so her skin is blue her
hairstyle is also different and in
eternals she's not a human but she's
made to look like a human so there was
enough difference there that Marvel
Studios decided that it was okay however
Jake Gyllenhaal played the main villain
of Spider-Man far from home and he was a
human Reed Richards is also a human and
of course one of the main characters of
the Fantastic Four in fact one of the
main characters of the entire Marvel
Comics universe and just marvel in
general so this will definitely be
noticeable so even if they decide to
have Jake Gyllenhaal to cast him as Reed
Richards even if they make him from
Another Universe it's still going to be
kind of odd for some people but having
him come from a different Universe can
actually work story wise in the MCU at
least leading up to Secret Wars what
happens after that's debatable but when
reports came out about this Grace
Randolph took to Twitter and posted this
should Jake Gyllenhaal be the new Mr
Fantastic or stay as Mysterio my vote is
to return as Mysterio he was great and
what's interesting is that she did a
poll asking people what they thought and
out of over 11 000 people 78 said that
he should stay as Mysterio but then she
followed up to this tweet stating I
checked on this crazy rumor and it
shockingly seems to be true so there's
another Insider backing that up and she
went on to tweet this also I hear the
most recent draft of the Fantastic Four
has them coming from not just the 19 60s
but also a different Universe than the
main MCU now this works originally
because we are in the Multiverse Saga
right now and we are leading up to the
events of Secret Wars where incursions
are going to start to happen and
universes are going to start to collide
we had heard rumors before that the
events that happened between Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars some of these
movies or shows could actually take
place in Another Universe and this
report does fall into those rumors that
we've been hearing so we know that our
universe is going to come in contact
with people from other universes and we
do know that doctor strange ran it to
read Richard's before where he was
deemed the smartest man alive so when
Doctor Strange goes about trying to fix
the Multiverse which he has already kind
of started to do with CLIA when she
showed up saying you caused an incursion
we're gonna fix it he went with her so
when he continues to do that he's going
to realize that the Earth 838 Universe
knew a lot about the Multiverse so he
should probably try to find a Reed
Richards of Another Universe first he
might check our universe but we might
not not have a Reed Richards in our
universe in fact if they're going to
make the movie about the Fantastic Four
and set that in a different Universe I
would rather know Reed Richards exist in
our universe because otherwise really
what's the point but if it is Jake
Gyllenhaal it would make sense that they
wouldn't have a fantastic four in our
main universe that way you can't say he
is two different people in the same
universe and since we are going to see
incursions happen this could work
whatever Universe the Fantastic Four are
going to be in could collide with our
universe and then they're here or
perhaps it's some type of a battle World
situation where a lot of different
universes combine together and our
heroes meet heroes from other universes
that's how they could come in contact
with the Fantastic Four this works story
wise for Secret Wars and the Multiverse
Saga the only question is how does it
work after we don't know what's going to
happen after the events of Secret Wars
we don't know if all the incursions are
going to be undone if the universe is
going to be put exactly the way as it
was before or if a completely new
Multiverse is going to be set up or if
only one timeline one sacred timeline is
going to be set up again much like he
who remains made we really don't know
what is going to happen and if
everything reverts back to normal then
it doesn't really make sense for the
Fantastic Four to be from Another
Universe because they in theory should
just go back to that universe so if this
report is true that the Fantastic Four
movie will take place in a completely
different universe that might actually
give us a little bit of a sign of where
Marvel's heading with the ending of
Secret Wars perhaps the Multiverse
doesn't get reset to the exact ways it
was before but perhaps then after Secret
Wars we will then go into a new saga
with phase 7 phase 8 phase 9 and however
many phases they want to put in the new
saga but go into this new saga where our
main MCU timeline is actually not the
way it was before but a combination of
different universes that survived the
multiversal war and are now left to be
not separate universes but one Universe
this is what has been theorized for a
while one of the options at least and
it's an option that I actually like
because this could also be a great
explanation as to why we haven't seen
any mutants or X-Men in the MCU or at
least we haven't seen any in the
traditional form yes Miss Marvel was
retconned to be a mutant and we have
also seen nameor but this would kind of
solve the reason why we haven't seen an
official X-Men team this entire time or
the Fantastic Four they might not exist
in our universe but Secret Wars will
obviously have all of them come together
and if all of the universes are kind of
fused into one or two or several
different universes then this could
definitely answer the question of why we
haven't seen them so far in our universe
they might not have been there but
fusing some universes together after
Secret Wars instead of being able to
just Resurrect The Multiverse as it was
before makes sense and it would honestly
be pretty fresh and exciting and if
Marvel Studios is looking to switch it
up a little bit this is definitely one
way to do that so this could work it
definitely works leading up to Avengers
Secret Wars that makes sense but would
it work after let us know what you think
about this down below in the comments do
you like it do you hate it will you give
it a chance let us know all of your
thoughts about this and please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU news you can also follow us
on Instagram and Twitter if you'd like
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof